This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧精神、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后变得更加快乐、更加充实、更加健康。收听《2%》。即在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“TWO”百分比。在“Look Back at it”播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听learn the hard way。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《陷入爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们的含义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.
为了我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析我们二十岁的心理。
I just want to jump in early to this episode and thank you all for the love that you have shown my relatively new podcast mantra. I know I've been talking about it a lot. recently, but if you didn't know, I actually have another podcast. It's called mantra. And every Monday, I give you an affirmation, a powerful phrase or statement to carry you through the week. And we explore the philosophy, the spirituality, the psychology behind what makes that phrase work. For example, recent mantras that I've covered include, I know that love won't
我想在这集节目刚开始时，感谢大家对我这个相对较新的播客《Mantra》所给予的喜爱。我知道我最近一直在谈论它。但如果你还不知道，其实我还有另一个播客。它叫Mantra。每周一，我会给你一条肯定语，一句强有力的短语或陈述，来陪伴你度过这一周。我们还将探讨让这句短语发挥作用背后的哲学、灵性和心理学。例如，我最近探讨过的肯定语包括：我知道爱不会
pass me. I release the need to do it all. I cultivate peace. within. It's one mantra every Monday to help anger you in the present, to help, I guess, just ground you and give you some kind of clarity in your life. So if you haven't checked that out, and if you love the psychology of your 20s, I'll leave a link in the description because I think you would really, really enjoy it. With that in mind, let's get into this episode. A bit of a controversial episode, an episode where I am sure people will, not agree with me on some of my takes, but I'm very much looking forward to the discussion, and you guys know I'm very much looking forward to being proven wrong, or just hearing what
与我擦肩而过。我释放了包办一切的需求。我内心培养平静。这是每周一的一个肯定语，旨在帮助你锚定在当下，我想，只是为了让你脚踏实地，并在你的生活中给你某种清晰度。所以，如果你还没有听过，如果你喜欢《你二十岁的心理学》，我会在简介里留下一个链接，因为我想你一定会非常非常喜欢的。带着这个，让我们进入这一集。这是一个稍微有点争议的话题，我相信在某些观点上，人们会不赞同我的看法，但我非常期待接下来的讨论，你们也知道，我非常期待被证明是错的，或者只是听听
other people's perspectives are. We're talking about age gap relationships. I recently saw this BuzzFeed article, and I know BuzzFeed is such a relic of the past, but I saw this article speaking about famous Hollywood couples known for having a significant age gap, Beyonce and Jay-Z, Leonardo DiCaprio and literally everyone he's ever dated. Some of these people were even born decades apart. You know, Chris Jenner, Corey Gamble, George Clooney, Amal Clooney. And that article didn't really surprise me. The comments, though, were, I don't want to say shocking, but really psychologically,
其他人的视角是什么。我们来谈谈年龄差恋爱。我最近看到了这篇BuzzFeed的文章，我知道BuzzFeed已经成了过去的遗物，但我看到了这篇文章，谈论的是以年龄差距大而闻名的好莱坞明星情侣，碧昂丝和Jay-Z，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥和几乎他约会过的所有人。其中一些人甚至相差几十岁。你知道的，克里斯·詹娜、科里·甘布尔，乔治·克鲁尼、阿玛尔·克鲁尼。那篇文章并没有真正让我惊讶。不过评论却——我不想说是震惊，但从心理学角度来看，真是
sociologically interesting how split down the middle people were about these kinds of relationships. And it got me thinking with something so sensationalized as age. gap relationships that has spoken about and dissected so often in the media, how do they actually work? How can people even decades apart be attracted to each other and form long-lasting successful relationships when you would assume that their mindsets and their mental age would be so very different? Is there a special secret number that makes age gap relationships appropriate and not. Where is the line between when we understand them and when they start to feel a little bit maybe uncomfortable? I really wanted to know what are the dynamics that make these relationships
社会学上很有趣的是，人们对这种关系的看法竟然如此分裂。这让我开始思考，年龄差恋爱这种被极大煽动的话题，在媒体中被如此频繁地讨论和剖析，它们实际上是如何运作的呢？为什么相差几十岁的人能够互相吸引，并建立长期且成功的关系，而你本会认为他们的思维方式和心理年龄会有天壤之别呢？是否存在一个特殊的秘密数字，让年龄差恋爱变得合适，而不再合适？我们理解它们与它们开始让人觉得稍微有点不舒服的界限在哪里？我真的很想知道，是什么动力让这些关系
work? Why do we have an implicit societal judgment about these relationships? Is that judgment fair? And that's really what we're going to explore today. Not just the public opinion about age gap relationships, but the psychology about it. And there is a lot to this topic. It's not just as simple as an age difference. We really need to talk about individual needs, dating preferences, maturity, expectations, societal pressures, developmental psychology. I think the reason that people have varying and different opinions on these kinds of relationships is that it's often against the story that we have been told about our lives and romantic love. The story that says you meet someone around your age, maybe in college, maybe through friends or at your first real job,
发挥作用？为什么我们对这些关系有一种隐含的社会评判？这种评判公平吗？这正是我们今天要探讨的内容。不仅是公众对年龄差恋爱的看法，还有背后的心理学。这个话题有很多内容。它不仅仅是一个年龄差那么简单。我们真的需要讨论个人需求、约会偏好、成熟度、期望、社会压力、发展心理学。我认为人们对这类关系持有不同和多样化意见的原因，是因为它通常违背了我们被灌输关于生活和浪漫爱情的故事。那个故事说，你会遇到一个年龄相仿的人，也许在大学里，也许通过朋友或在你的第一份真正工作中，
you date, you get serious, you get engaged, you get married, probably around the same time that all your friends are doing it, you might buy your first home, you know, you might have children, you grow old together, you're hitting all these predictable major milestones at the same time. When an age gap is introduced, basically it gets kind of confusing. When do you choose to have kids? What if that person already has kids, can you actually be with someone who is much older than you or is it going to, you know, intrinsically, automatically set up a power imbalance? There's all these whispers of trophy partners or sugar daddies or hidden agendas or manipulation. Is that assessment fair?
你们约会，关系变得认真，订婚，结婚，可能和你们所有朋友做这件事的时间差不多，你们可能会买下第一套房子，你知道的，你们可能会生孩子，你们一起变老，在同一时间达到所有这些可预测的重大里程碑。当引入年龄差距时，基本上事情就变得有点混乱了。你什么时候选择要孩子？如果那个人已经有孩子了呢，你真的能和一个比你大得多的人在一起吗，还是它会（你知道的）内在地、自动地建立起权力不平衡？这里有各种关于奖杯伴侣、干爹、隐藏动机或操纵的窃窃私语。这种评估公平吗？
So we're going to explore the why behind the attraction. We're going to explore the stereotypes. We're going to talk about not just romantic age gap relationships, but platonic ones as well. And we're also going to unpack, can these relationships work? What are the unique dynamics and challenges that they are going to face? And how can we maybe confront our own biases and rethink what an age gap relationship really means? Not just for the two people in it, but for society in general. So there is a lot to discuss. I know I always say this.
所以我们将探讨吸引力背后的原因。我们将探讨刻板印象。我们不仅要谈论浪漫的年龄差关系，还要谈论柏拉图式的关系。我们还将剖析，这些关系能成功吗？它们将面临哪些独特的动态和挑战？我们如何才能面对自己的偏见，重新思考年龄差关系的真正含义？不仅仅是对身处其中的两个人，对整个社会也是如此。所以有很多东西要讨论。我知道我总是这么说。
There is a lot of psychology that you may not have expected. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of age gap relationship. So before we go any further, I need to make a really serious but important distinction, one that is absolutely critical to this entire conversation. When we talk about age gap relationships on this podcast, we are exclusively talking about relationships between consenting adults. This is a non-negotiable point. The very idea of an age gap is deeply problematic and frankly dangerous when it is applied to relationships involving minors or younger people. In those situations, we're not talking about a discussion, we're not talking about a debate. There is no route or wrong answer. It's wrong. It's exploitation. It's
有很多你可能意想不到的心理学知识。闲话少说，让我们进入年龄差恋爱的心理学。所以在我们深入探讨之前，我需要做一个非常严肃但重要的区分，这对整个对话绝对至关重要。当我们在本播客中谈论年龄差恋爱时，我们专门讨论的是成年人之间的自愿关系。这是一个不可妥协的观点。当年龄差距的概念应用于涉及未成年人或较年轻人的关系时，是非常有问题的，坦率地说也是危险的。在这种情况下，我们不是在讨论，我们不是在辩论。没有对错答案。这是错的。这是剥削。这是
abuse. It's illegal. The power imbalance, the developmental differences and the capacity for true consent are fundamentally absent when one person is a child, even if they're mature for their age, even if they've graduated high school, whatever it is. Also, We are not at all about supporting relationships where grooming has taken place and someone has waited until someone is freshly 18 or 19 to start a serious relationship but was, you know, secretly attracted to them for much longer. Still not okay. Just because it may be legal doesn't mean that it's right.
虐待。这是非法的。当其中一个人是个孩子时，权力不平衡、发展差异以及真正同意的能力从根本上是不存在的，即使他们心理成熟，即使他们高中毕业了，无论如何。此外，我们根本不支持那种伴侣经过“诱导（grooming）”并且有人等到对方刚满18或19岁才开始认真恋爱，但（你知道的）其实暗地里被对方吸引了更长时间的关系。这仍然不可以。仅仅因为它可能是合法的，并不意味着它是对的。
I think when we are young, an acceptable age gap is going to be smaller than between someone who is, say, in their late 20s or 30s or 40s because of the amount of growth. that you're going through. It is so rapid. You know, the difference between 19 and 25 and 35, like those are much bigger jumps in terms of understanding and experiences and mental maturity compared to the jump between 27, 37, 47, 47, or 57. And that is something that we really need to acknowledge. If anyone is trying to justify a relationship that started when someone was 16 or 17 or 18 or even 19, and the other person was much older or in a position of developmental power. Doesn't have a place here.
我认为当我们年轻时，一个可以接受的年龄差距要比那些处于二十多岁、三十多岁或四十多岁的人之间要小，因为你正在经历的成长
Sorry, it's just creepy. We're not going to be accepting rebuttals on that fact. But with that vital point really established, let's talk about consenting age gap relationships starting at the very beginning, why they occur in the first place, and breaking down the attraction itself. So generally, when psychologists talk about age gap relationships, they are referring to a romantic partnership
非常迅速。你知道的，19岁与25岁和35岁的区别，就理解、经历和心理成熟度而言，这些跨度要大得多，相比之下，27岁、37岁、47岁、47岁或57岁之间的跨度则不然。这是我们需要真正承认的事情。如果有人试图为一段始于某人16岁、17岁、18岁甚至19岁，而另一方要大得多或处于发展权力地位的关系辩护。这里没有容身之地。
where there's an age difference of seven years or more between partners. Now, of course, I think five or six years can even feel particularly significant depending on your life stage, especially when you're in your early 20s. You know, five years can mean the difference between still being at university and having a mortgage, but seven to ten years is often the threshold used in the research. So that's going to be our starting point today. Let's begin with the question. Why is it that people are drawn to someone who is significantly older or significantly younger?
抱歉，这真的很令人毛骨悚然。我们不会接受对此事实的反驳。但既然确立了这一至关重要的观点，让我们从最开始谈谈双方自愿的年龄差关系，为什么它们会首先出现，并剖析吸引力本身。通常，当心理学家谈论年龄差关系时，他们指的是浪漫伴侣
We really cannot talk about this without mentioning evolutionary psychology, of course. So David Buss, he's one of the leading voices in this field. He has spent decades studying mate preferences across cultures, including those with an age gap. And interestingly, what he has found in studies spanning more than 30 countries, is actually pretty consistent. Heterosexual men, on average, tend to prefer younger women, typically women in their mid-20s, regardless of their own age, whereas women, on the other hand, tend to prefer slightly older men,
伴侣之间的年龄差在七年或以上。当然，我认为根据你所处的人生阶段，五到六年甚至也会让人觉得特别明显，特别是当你二十出头的时候。你知道的，五年可能意味着还在上大学和背负房贷的区别，但研究中经常使用的阈值是七到十年。所以这将是我们今天的起点。让我们从这个问题开始。为什么人们会被明显比自己大或比自己小的人吸引？
often by about three to five years, sometimes more. I just want to say a lot of this research, if not all of it, is very heteronormative. I really did search for articles on lesbian or queer couples or gay men, and there is basically nothing. So if you're in the market for a cool PhD or research project, this is a good place to start. But for now, the research we have mainly focuses on straight men and women.
当然，如果不提及进化心理学，我们真的无法谈论这一点。戴维·巴斯（David Buss）是该领域的领军人物之一。他花了数十年时间研究跨文化的伴侣偏好，包括那些有年龄差距的伴侣。有趣的是，他在跨越30多个国家的研究所发现的结果实际上相当一致。异性恋男性平均而言更倾向于年轻女性，通常是二十岁出头的女性，无论他们自己的年龄如何；而另一方面，女性则倾向于稍微年长的男性，
And this pattern appears to be pretty consistent. According to an evolutionary model, men would be drawn to signals of fertility and youth, which would often indicate reproductive viability. The idea is that men just want to have offspring, who are they going to have the best chances with, someone who was younger. That's the theory. Women, conversely, are theorized to really look for signals of stability, resources,
通常大三到五岁，有时更多。我只想说，这项研究的很大一部分（如果不是全部的话）是非常异性恋规范的。我确实搜索了关于女同性恋、酷儿情侣或男同性恋的文章，但基本上什么都没有。所以如果你正在寻找一个很酷的博士学位或研究项目，这是一个很好的起点。但就目前而言，我们拥有的研究主要集中在异性恋男女身上。
and the ability to protect and provide, traits that often accumulate with age and experience. So this is all part of something we call sexual selection theory, and it explains why these preferences might show up in large population studies based on parts, of our biology as humans and parts of our animal nature. Now, of course, there are nuances to this. Scientists are going deeper and what they found is it's not just that women like older, men like younger. When you dig deeper, it's that women who are before 40, so younger women tend to prefer a larger age gap, but as women get older, they actually prefer someone their own age. or someone even younger.
这种模式似乎相当一致。根据进化模型，男性会被生育力和年轻的信号所吸引，这通常表明繁殖能力。这个想法是，男性只是想有后代，他们和谁有最好的机会呢，一个更年轻的人。这就是理论。相反，据理论推测，女性真正寻找的是稳定、资源信号，
So maybe the data that we're collecting is only looking at a certain group of women or the preferences of older women are kind of getting suppressed by certain data sets. Men, on the other hand, do typically like the same age from the age of 20 to the age of 60. But again, just because the data has a median, just because the data has a trend, doesn't necessarily mean that it represents every single person. You cannot take one study, one data set and say, look, there we go, men like younger, women like older, that is the truth of the universe.
以及保护和提供能力，这些特质往往随年龄和经验而积累。所以这都是我们称之为性选择理论的一部分，它解释了为什么这些偏好可能会基于我们作为人类的生物学部分和动物本性部分，出现在大型人口研究中。当然，这里面是有细微差别的。科学家们正在深入研究，他们发现不仅是女性喜欢年长的，男性喜欢年轻的。当你深入挖掘时，你会发现40岁之前的女性，也就是年轻女性，倾向于更大的年龄差距，但随着女性年龄增长，她们实际上更喜欢同龄人。甚至比自己更年轻的人。
What's even more fascinating is a recent study from actually start of this year, January 2025, that looked at over 6,000 blind dates. And it found that whilst women report wanting older partners in social, surveys, actually in blind date scenarios, they are just as attracted to younger partners as men were. And this suggests that there might be a difference between what we think we prefer and what actually sparks attraction and real life interactions. So if you're only basing your data on self-reporting, so if you're only basing it on asking someone, do you like older men, do you like younger men,
所以也许我们收集的数据只观察了特定的一群人，或者年长女性的偏好在某种程度上被某些数据集压制了。另一方面，男性从20岁到60岁通常确实喜欢同龄人。但是，再次强调，仅仅因为数据有一个中位数，仅仅因为数据有一个趋势，并不一定意味着它代表了每一个人。你不能拿一项研究、一个数据集就说，看，就是这样，男人喜欢年轻的，女人喜欢年长的，这就是宇宙的真理。
do you like older women, do you like younger women? People are going to say something. different to what they might reflect in a real-life scenario. And here's where the critics of this evolutionary theory would jump in and make some very valid points. We are not just animals. This perspective is overly deterministic. It's too focused on biology, not enough on culture, not enough on the complexities of human beings and individual choice and rational preferences, it might actually come down to the qualities
更令人着迷的是最近的一项研究，实际上是今年年初，即2025年1月进行的，该研究调查了6000多场相亲。研究发现，虽然女性在社会调查中报告说想要年长的伴侣，但实际上在相亲场景中，她们对年轻伴侣的吸引力与男性一样大。这表明，我们认为自己偏好的东西与实际在现实互动中点燃吸引力的东西之间可能存在差异。所以，如果你只把数据建立在自我报告的基础上，也就是只建立在询问某人：你喜欢年长的男人吗？你喜欢年轻的男人吗？
of the individual rather than this primal urge. Because I think a lot of us can't relate to that. I personally cannot relate to this very simplistic biological idea that I should like older men because that's what would be best for having offspring. Like I think it really does reduce people to just wanting to their, I don't know, drive to have children. And if you don't want children, like, how do you fit into this model? And if, you know, you can't have children, how do you fit into this model? Like, you can see that it's very, it's one dimensional.
你喜欢年长的女人吗？你喜欢年轻的女人吗？人们说出的东西可能会与他们在现实生活场景中反映的东西不同。这就是这种进化理论的批评者会介入并提出一些非常有效观点的地方。我们不仅仅是动物。这种观点过于决定论。它太过于关注生物学，对文化关注不够，对人类的复杂性、个人选择和理性偏好的关注也不够，它实际上可能归结为个人品质，
It doesn't fit everyone. Let's talk about this quality-based theory behind age gap relations. So basically, the second theory goes to say that the reason that age gap relationships are more prevalent amongst certain people or the reason people choose them is actually because it's not just what age reflects, it's what experience reflects. If you're the younger partner, the draw to an older individual might come from a personal desire for factors like maturity, stability, and guidance. That's what you want in a partner.
而不是这种原始冲动。因为我认为我们中的很多人都无法对此产生共鸣。我个人无法与这种过于简化的生物学观点产生共鸣，即我应该喜欢年长的男人，因为那是生养后代最好的方式。我觉得这确实把人们贬低为仅仅想要他们——我不知道——生育孩子的冲动。如果你不想要孩子，你怎么契合这个模型？如果，你知道的，你不能生育孩子，你怎么契合这个模型？所以你可以看出它是非常一维的。
and that's something you may have been struggling to find in a 21-year-old or a 27-year-old. It's not that if a 27-year-old or a 21-year-old came along and had all of those factors you would say no, it's just that it's hard to find them. So now imagine meeting someone, say, 10 or 15 years older. They've already navigated a significant chunk of that early adult chaos. They might be firmly established in their career. They might have their own home, a clear sense of who they are. a clear sense of what they want, a lot of wisdom.
它并不适合所有人。让我们来谈谈年龄差恋爱背后的这种基于品质的理论。基本上，第二种理论认为，年龄差恋爱在某些人当中更普遍的原因，或者人们选择它们的原因，实际上是因为这不仅关乎年龄所反映的东西，还关乎经验所反映的东西。如果你是年龄较小的一方，被年长者吸引可能源于对成熟、稳定和指导等因素的个人渴望。这就是你在伴侣身上想要的，
If that's something that you always have desired in a partner, you can see why this would be incredibly appealing. They also might introduce you to new things, new ideas, better restaurants, a sense of quiet comfort that feels, you know, very far away from dating in your 20s, where it's situationships and one night stands. It's a personal preference. Age is just a number. I guess that's what I'm trying to say.
而这可能是你在一个21岁或27岁的人身上一直在努力寻找却找不到的。并不是说如果来了一个27岁或21岁的人并且具备所有这些因素你会拒绝，只是说很难找到他们。所以现在想象一下，遇到一个比你大10岁或15岁的人。他们已经度过了早期成人混乱的很大一部分。他们可能已经在事业上稳固建立。他们可能有自己的房子，对我是谁有清晰的认识。对他们想要什么有清晰的认识，有很多智慧。
But the experiences and the mindset that come from age is what appeals to you, based on a dating preference that could actually be met by someone your own age. Let's flip the script. What might an older partner find attractive in someone younger? You know what? I'm going to admit my prejudices here and say that I used to think that the only reason that an older man or, well, mainly an older man would date a younger woman is just because she was hot and because she may have been easy to manipulate.
如果这是你一直渴望在伴侣身上拥有的东西，你能看出为什么这会具有难以抗拒的吸引力。他们也可能会向你介绍新事物、新想法、更好的餐厅，一种安静的舒适感，这种感觉（你知道的）离你二十多岁时的约会非常遥远，在那个年纪到处都是无名分恋爱（situationships）和一夜情。这是一种个人偏好。年龄只是一个数字。我想这就是我想表达的。
That is really what I used to believe. But having discussions with my friends, like I've come to realize, that it's more complex. And I'm glad that they kind of called me out on what was a very, I think, old school bias. For someone who is older, it's not just that a younger person might be, you know, more youthful and they find that more attractive. It often has to do with energy. This is what people have explained to me.
但源自年龄的经历和思维方式才是吸引你的地方，基于一个完全可以由与你同龄的人来满足的约会偏好。让我们反转剧本。年长的伴侣可能会在年轻的人身上发现什么吸引力呢？你知道吗？我要在这里承认我的偏见，并说我过去认为一个老男人——或者，好吧，主要是一个老男人——和一个年轻女人约会的唯一原因只是因为她性感，而且因为她可能很容易被操纵。
Energy, a fresh perspective, unbridled enthusiasm for life. If you're an older partner, the attraction to someone younger may stem from that real desire for vitality. maybe as you get into your 30s and your 40s, life can feel very routine. And someone who's in their 20s brings a sense of adventure and excitement and spontaneity. They might challenge you. There's also a sense of validation, feeling desired and attractive to someone who represents youth and beauty. That can be a really powerful boost to self-esteem as one ages. I just watched materialist the other day.
这真的是我过去所相信的。但通过与朋友们的讨论，比如我开始意识到，事情要复杂得多。我很高兴他们指出了我过去那种非常老派的偏见。对于一个年长的人来说，不仅是一个年轻人可能更年轻，他们觉得这更有吸引力。这通常与精力有关。这就是人们向我解释的。
I'm going to say it's a terrible movie. I really didn't like it. But one thing did stand out and it was way. When Dakota Johnson is talking to that bride who is getting married and she says, you want to marry him because he makes you feel valuable. Really, that's why we want to be with anyone. They make us feel valuable for whatever reason. And if you're an older person, the same interaction is at play here.
精力、新鲜的视角、对生活不加掩饰的热情。如果你是一个年长的伴侣，对年轻人的吸引力可能源于对活力的真正渴望。也许当你进入三十多岁和四十多岁时，生活会让人觉得非常常规。而一个二十多岁的人带来了一种冒险、兴奋和自发性的感觉。他们可能会挑战你。这里还有一种认可感，在一个年龄歧视严重的社会中，感受到来自代表青春和美貌的人的渴望和吸引，这种社会会告诉你，你越老价值就越低。这可以极大地提升随着年龄增长的自尊心。我前几天刚看了一部名为《Materialists》的电影。
They make you feel valuable even in a very ageist society who would tell you that the older you get, the less worth you have. If we really think about this through a lens of social exchange theory, this might help us understand it from a more cost benefit perspective. Social exchange theory basically says that any relationship can be seen as an exchange where both parties seek to maximize rewards and minimize costs. Obviously, this might be unconscious when you're in love and, you know, desperately devoted and loyal and desiring of someone. but in any age gap relationship there is an exchange, youth and beauty, vitality on one side for stability, wisdom and resources. The same way that any other couple has an exchange of their own, an age gap relationship exchange
我要说这是一部糟糕的电影。我真的很不喜欢它。但有一件事确实很突出，那就是韦（Way）。当达科塔·约翰逊和那个即将结婚的新娘交谈时，她说，你想嫁给他，是因为他让你觉得有价值。真的，这就是为什么我们想和任何人在一起。无论出于什么原因，他们让我们感到有价值。如果你是一个年长的人，同样的互动在这里也在起作用。
might just be a little bit more obvious in those certain areas. And it might sound mathematical, but it's simply acknowledging that different life stages offer different currencies. the same way that different perspectives often different currencies and a relationship might feel balanced despite an age gap if both partners perceive themselves as getting something valuable and deeply needed from the other. It's really about finding completeness that might be missing from the relationships that you may be having with your peers.
即使在一个非常年龄歧视的社会里，它也会告诉你你越老价值越低，而他们却让你感到有价值。如果我们真正通过社会交换理论的视角来思考这个问题，这可能有助于我们从更具成本效益的角度理解它。社会交换理论基本上说，任何关系都可以被视为一种交换，双方都试图将奖励最大化并使成本最小化。很明显，当你坠入爱河并且（你知道的）对某人极度忠诚、奉献和渴望时，这可能是无意识的，但在任何年龄差恋爱中，都存在一种交换，一方提供青春、美貌、活力，另一方提供稳定、智慧和资源。就像任何其他情侣都有他们自己的交换一样，年龄差恋爱的交换
And again, it does sometimes just come down to mental age and it comes down to your mindset, whether you want someone who was younger or older based on how you see yourself. So I want to talk about something else, a little bit of a little bit of a sidebar, if you will. I want to talk about platonic friendships with an age gap because I think a discussion of this fits well into the social exchange theory, right? We cannot just see age gap relationships only through a romantic lens. Having non-romantic bonds that are intergenerational is incredibly powerful. It's something that I personally think that we need to have more of.
可能只是在那些特定领域更明显一点。这听起来可能很数学化，但它只是承认不同的人生阶段提供不同的货币。就像不同的视角往往提供不同的货币一样，尽管存在年龄差距，但如果双方都认为自己从对方那里得到了他们有价值且深切需要的东西，那么这种关系可能会觉得是平衡的。这实际上是关于寻找可能在你与同龄人的交往中缺失的完整性。
One of my most amazing greatest friends, someone I really treasure as a friend whose name is Emma, she's in her 50s. And we met at a ceramics class and she was amazing. We just kept doing courses with each other and she comes to parties of mine. She comes to book events. She brings me honey from her bumblebees and we talk about everything and I trust her opinion so much on what's happening in my life. And I remember last year when I was going through a tough time, like she just gave me the most beautiful advice. And it was advice that I don't think I could have gotten from a friend around my age because they hadn't lived through it the way that she lived through it.
再次强调，有时这确实归结为心理年龄，归结为你的心态，即根据你如何看待自己，你是想要一个更年轻的人还是更年长的人。所以我想谈谈别的事情，如果你愿意的话，算是一个小小的插曲。我想谈谈有年龄差距的柏拉图式友谊，因为我认为对这一点的讨论很符合社会交换理论，对吧？我们不能仅仅通过浪漫的视角来看待年龄差恋爱。拥有跨代的非浪漫纽带是非常强大的。我个人认为这是我们需要更多拥有的东西。
And if we can see that there is this beautiful exchange between people like me and Emma, we can see how that might translate in a romantic sense as well. But from a platonic sense, these relationships are so valuable. Maybe it's like an older colleague who's like become a mentor or your elderly neighbor that like retell stories of when they were younger or a younger family member or a cousin or a sibling's friend who like keeps you in on all the goss and all like the trends and whatever. Like they bring about such a different perspective that we are missing and in a world where I think we are increasingly burrowing into our bubbles and we are increasingly only seeking our opinions. that maybe match our own or experiences that match our own, having people who are different to us, not just in terms of race or religion or ethnicity or beliefs, but age as well is actually really, really valuable
我最了不起、最伟大的朋友之一，我真正珍视的一个朋友，名叫艾玛，她五十多岁了。我们是在一个陶艺班认识的，她太棒了。我们只是不断地一起上课，她会来参加我的派对。她来参加我的图书活动。她给我带来她养的熊蜂酿的蜜，我们什么都聊，我非常相信她对我的生活中所发生的事情的看法。我记得去年我经历艰难时期的时候，她给了我最美好的建议。那是我想象不到能从一个年龄相仿的朋友那里得到的建议，因为他们没有经历过她那样的人生。
and they can bring you so many new ideas and they can challenge your assumptions. So actually, I went looking for research to confirm this, and it wasn't that hard to find. There was a study done in 2016 from the Stanford Center of Longevity, that found that intergenerational relationships are incredibly important for life satisfaction, for learning, and provide a really deep sense of companionship. It's really good for us in our 20s, but it's also good for the older generation.
如果我们能看到我和艾玛这样的人之间存在着这种美好的交换，我们就能看到这在浪漫意义上是如何转化的。但从柏拉图式的意义上讲，这些关系是如此宝贵。也许就像一个年长的同事像个导师一样，或者你年长的邻居讲述他们年轻时的故事，或者一个年轻的家庭成员、表亲或兄弟姐妹的朋友，让你了解所有的八卦和所有的潮流等等。他们带来了截然不同的视角，这是我们所缺少的，在一个我认为我们越来越多地钻进自己的气泡中，我们越来越只寻求我们的意见的世界里。
A 22 study of over 5,000 people who are over 60 found that the ones who had close friends under the age of 50 and under the age of 40 even actually felt younger and they were more likely to be physically active, they were more like to be socially active as well. And you know what? This is a less fun statistic, but I think it's worth mentioning. Nearly one third of seniors said that it had been at least five years since they'd made a new friend. Five years since they, you know, had a new person in their life who was interested in them and who cared about them and who could talk to them. And I think our generation is also equally struggling with loneliness. And it's like, here is this solution that is right in front of us if we can get over the stereotypes of what we think is
也许这与我们自己的匹配，或者与我们自己的经历匹配，拥有与我们不同的人，不仅在种族、宗教、民族或信仰方面，而且在年龄方面实际上非常非常有价值，他们可以给你带来很多新想法，他们可以挑战你的假设。事实上，我去寻找研究来证实这一点，并不难找到。斯坦福长寿中心在2016年做过一项研究，发现跨代关系对生活满意度、学习至关重要，并提供了非常深厚的陪伴感。这不仅对我们二十多岁的人有好处，对老一辈也很有好处。
expected from us socially. And if we can get over this idea that it's weird to have older friends or it's weird to be friends with people who are younger than you. Absolutely not. What these platonic bonds I think really highlight is that we all have this core human desire for companionship that transcends age. When you find someone, regardless of their birth year, with whom you share values, intellectual curiosity, genuine mutual respect. A very powerful relationship can bloom, platonic or non-plotonic. This is your reminder. Talk to older people.
一项针对5000多名60岁以上人群的22年研究发现，那些拥有50岁以下甚至40岁以下亲密朋友的人实际上感觉更年轻，他们更有可能进行体育活动，他们也更有可能进行社交活动。你知道吗？这是一个不那么有趣但我觉得值得一提的统计数据。近三分之一的老年人表示，他们至少已经五年没有交过新朋友了。距离他们（你知道的）生活中出现一个对他们感兴趣、关心他们并能与他们交谈的新人已经过去了五年。我认为我们这一代人同样也在努力应对孤独。这就像是，如果我们可以克服社会对我们的预期所带来的刻板印象，这个解决方案就在我们眼前。
Make friends with the people who are 10, 20, 40 years older than you. They will teach you so much valuable stuff. And it's not just about what they can teach you. They're also, like you could just have a friend, like a regular old friend who you hang out with and who you get drinks with and who you get coffee. with, and I think that's amazing. We all need more friends. Now that I've taken that, I think very necessary detour, but very weird detour, we are going to circle back to romantic relationships, particularly the unique challenges they might face and when an age gap relationship should be
如果我们能克服那种认为交年长朋友很奇怪，或者和比自己年轻的人做朋友很奇怪的想法。绝对不是。我认为这些柏拉图式的纽带真正突显的是，我们所有人都有超越年龄的对陪伴的核心渴望。当你找到一个人，无论他们的出生年份如何，你与他们分享价值观、求知欲、真正的相互尊重时。一段非常强大的关系就会绽放，无论是柏拉图式的还是非柏拉图式的。这是对你的提醒。与老年人交谈。
called into question. So stay with us. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also and escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
和那些比你大10岁、20岁、40岁的人交朋友。他们会教给你很多有价值的东西。这不仅关乎他们能教给你什么。他们也是，就像你可以只有一个朋友，一个普通的老朋友，你和他一起出去玩，一起喝一杯，一起喝咖啡。我认为这太棒了。我们都需要更多的朋友。既然我已经进行了我认为非常必要的绕道，但也是非常奇怪的绕道，我们将绕回浪漫关系，特别是它们可能面临的独特挑战，以及什么时候应该对年龄差恋爱
and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
提出质疑。所以请留下来。稍事休息后我们马上回来。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧精神、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员对话。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends...
以及其他健康和健身专家等，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症吗？我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后变得更加快乐、更加充实、更加健康。收听《2%》。即在I-Hart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听T-W-O-Persent。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是这样说，相信你的女友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》这个新季节中……
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tap little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
哦，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？警察似乎不在乎，所以他们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for. sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
我随时准备在白天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你。句子。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
是的。对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的年份之一。在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我正在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐
Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different. levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. So once that initial spark is there, what are the unique dynamics and challenges that an age
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？
gap couple may face, especially as they navigate, you know, the very different waters of their respective life stages because I think whilst love may be blind, life stages certainly are not. And pretending that they don't exist is frankly not very helpful and will end up getting in the way. Firstly, the really critical issue that I think a lot of people in age gap relationships will encounter is social perception and stigma. Research in social psychology consistently shows that age gap relationships, particularly those where the woman is significantly older than the man or where the gap is very large, face a lot of external judgment and scrutiny. Whether that is fair or not is something we're going
还是你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同的。信任级别。我希望你真正成为一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the hard way》中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索Learn the hard way并立即收听。一旦最初的火花出现，年龄差情侣可能会面临哪些独特的动态和挑战，特别是当他们航行时，你知道的，各自人生阶段的不同水域，因为我认为虽然爱情可能是盲目的，但人生阶段绝对不是。假装它们不存在坦率地说并没有什么帮助，而且最终会碍事。首先，我认为年龄差恋爱中的许多人会遇到的一个真正关键的问题是社会认知和污渍。社会心理学研究一致表明，年龄差恋爱，特别是那些女性明显比男性年长或者差距非常大的关系，面临着大量的外部判断和审视。这是否公平是我们将会探讨的内容
to debate in a second. But, you know, friends might be wary, family might disapprove. Even strangers make assumptions, give you the bit of the side eye. This external pressure can be incredibly draining on the relationship. It requires the couple to be very secure in their bond. and to really develop strategies for dealing with this judgment. And it can definitely kind of foster a sense of us against the world. That can either strengthen a bond or isolate the couple or isolate an individual within the couple from leaving sometimes. And this stigma is often massively amplified and distorted by media representation. Think about how age gap relationships are usually portrayed on screen, in tabloids, in mainstream,
我们稍后会进行讨论。但是，你知道，朋友可能会有所戒备，家人可能会不赞同。甚至连陌生人也会妄加揣测，对你投来斜视的目光。这种外部压力对这段关系来说消耗巨大。它要求情侣双方对彼此的结合非常有安全感，并且真正制定出应对这种评判的策略。这绝对会催生出一种“我们与世界对抗”的感觉。这种感觉要么会巩固彼此的羁绊，要么会将情侣孤立起来，或者有时会让情侣中的某个人无法抽身。而且，这种污名往往被媒体的形象塑造无限放大和扭曲。想想看，年龄差距悬殊的恋爱关系在银幕上、小报里以及主流
news, they tend to fall into a few stereotypical categories, right? The Sugar Daddy, the Cougar, the Gold Digger, the Manipulator, even someone assuming that a younger woman has daddy issues. On the point of younger women with daddy issues actually liking older men, I actually want to tell you the research completely refutes this idea. 2016 study found that 74% of women in age gap relationships with older men were secure. attached, which is actually above the general population average of around 50 to 65%. So again, we are obviously getting some things wrong here. And those media portrayals, they do matter. It doesn't just, you know, reflect public opinion. It really shapes public opinion and means that
新闻中通常是如何被描绘的，它们往往落入几个刻板的类别，对吧？“糖爹”、“美洲狮”、“拜金女”、“操纵者”，甚至有人会揣测年轻女性有“恋父情结”。关于年轻女性有“恋父情结”且实际上喜欢年长男性的观点，我其实想告诉大家，研究完全反驳了这种说法。2016年的一项研究发现，在与年长男性的年龄差恋爱关系中，74%的女性拥有安全型依恋，这实际上高于大约50%至65%的普通人群平均水平。所以再次说明，我们在这里显然对某些事情存在误解。而这些媒体的描绘确实很重要。它不仅，你知道，反映了公众舆论。它真正塑造了公众舆论，这意味着
someone in a very healthy age gap relationship might feel that there are implicit biases about who they are with. So another of the most frequent. cited challenge in any age gap relationship is, of course, differing life stages. If you are in your 20s, you are right smack in the middle of what psychologists call emerging adulthood. This is a very unique, very important developmental period from around 18 to 29 that has five unique features to it. Identity exploration, instability, self-focus, feeling in between and the sense of multiple possibilities. Even if you think you are old for your age,
身处一段非常健康的年龄差恋爱关系中的人可能会觉得，别人对他们的伴侣身份带有隐含的偏见。因此，任何年龄差恋爱关系中被提及频率最高另一个挑战，当然就是不同的人生阶段。如果你正处于20多岁，你正处于心理学家所说的“成年期过渡阶段”的正中央。这是一个非常独特、非常重要的发展时期，大约从18岁持续到29岁，它有五个独特的特征：身份探索、不稳定、以自我为中心、处于两者之间的感觉以及拥有多种可能性的感觉。即使你觉得自己比实际年龄成熟，
these five things are undoubtedly happening to you in some form during this period of emerging adulthood. Now, imagine you're going through that and your partner is like way past their 20s. They've often already navigated a significant chunk of that early adult chaos and they have a clear sense of who they are and what they want. this can create very natural but often subtle divergences in daily life and daily priorities and social needs.
在成年期过渡的这段时期，这五种情况无疑都会以某种形式发生在你身上。现在，想象一下你正在经历这些，而你的伴侣已经远远走过了20多岁。他们通常已经度过了早期成年期混乱中的很大一部分，并且对自己是谁以及想要什么有着清晰的认识。这会在日常生活中、日常优先事项以及社交需求上产生非常自然但通常又很微妙的分歧。
Starting with social needs, you know, your idea of a good time might differ. Your social circles might differ. You know, for you, if you're in your early 20s, mid-20s, like your ideal Friday night might be a noisy pub or going out for drinks or doing something out and about whilst your partner may be finding that it's a quiet dinner with long-time friends or, their children or their family. And so merging these or maintaining separate social lives really does require conscious effort to find like an authentic shared ground between the younger one and the older one. If you are someone younger, dating someone older, you do have to consider whether you are going to feel like you're missing out. Do you want to be having the fun, young, free, careless experiences that everyone else is having. Particularly when it comes to dating, partying, traveling,
从社交需求开始，你知道，你对好时光的定义可能会有所不同。你们的社交圈可能会不同。你知道的，对你而言，如果你正处于20多岁出头或20多岁中期，你理想的周五晚上可能是一个嘈杂的酒吧，或者出去喝一杯，或者做一些热闹的户外活动，而你的合作伙伴可能会觉得这是一场与多年好友、他们的孩子或家人的安静晚餐。因此，融合这些需求或维持独立的社交生活确实需要付出有意识的努力，在年幼者和年长者之间找到一个真实的共同点。如果你是一个年轻人，正在和年长的人谈恋爱，你确实必须考虑自己是否会有一种“错失恐惧症”。你是否想体验那种其他人正在经历的有趣、年轻、自由、无忧无虑的生活？特别是当谈到约会、聚会、旅行时，
is that something that your current partner can provide you access to? Do they want to do it with you? Or maybe it's just not your thing at all and that's fine. But is there anything you really want to do that maybe would be better with a partner your own age? Or no. Again, it's a personal preference. Like there is no right answer. There's no judgment, but it is something to consider. Are there things that you are going to miss out on because of this relationship dynamic that may actually foster long-term resentment? It's a thing that comes up in any relationship. The idea that someone else is making you close doors for them or say no for them when you really want to say yes. You just have to consider that. Career trajectories are another thing that's probably going to vary.
这是你目前的伴侣能够带你体验的吗？他们想和你一起做吗？或者也许这根本不是你的菜，那也没关系。但是，有没有什么事是你真正想做的，也许和一个同龄的伴侣一起做会更好？或者没有。同样，这是一个个人偏好。没有所谓的标准答案。没有评判，但这确实是需要考虑的事情。你会不会因为这种恋爱关系的动态而错过一些事情，从而最终滋生出长期的怨恨？这是任何恋爱关系中都会出现的问题。那种觉得别人让你为他们关闭大门，或者在你真正想说“好”的时候替你拒绝的想法。你只需要考虑这一点。职业发展轨迹是另一个可能会存在差异的方面。
You might be intensely focused on getting internships, climbing the career ladder, building your professional identity, just not even knowing what you want. And your partner could be very settled in their career. And this often leads to differing priorities and also financial stresses. For example, you know, you might be saving to travel. They might be saving for a house or for their kids' college tuition. You know, these are significant differences and they really, really do demand open discussion around financial goals and lifestyle expectations just to ensure
你可能全神贯注于争取实习机会、在职场晋升、建立自己的职业认同，甚至根本不知道自己想要什么。而你的伴侣可能在事业上已经非常稳定。这通常会导致不同的优先事项以及经济压力。例如，你知道，你可能在攒钱去旅行。他们可能在攒钱买房子或者为他们孩子的大学学费存钱。你知道，这些都是重大的差异，它们确实非常需要围绕财务目标和生活方式期望展开公开讨论，仅仅是为了确保
that you are both on the same page. It's also about being safe about financial reliance. This is a conversation people don't want to have, but please, please, please make sure you have your own savings account, make sure that you are investing in your own financial literacy. a person, regardless of what age they are, is not a financial plan. Even if they can provide for you, you should still feel like if everything went to shit and you broke up or someone cheated or something worse happened, you could provide for yourself. You know, coercive control through money and finances is also a very real problem. and it's often exaggerated when there is an earning imbalance.
你们俩在同频共振。这也关乎防范财务依赖的安全意识。这是人们不愿进行的对话，但请务必、务必、务必确保你有自己的储蓄账户，确保你正在投资提升自己的财务素养。一个人，无论年龄多大，都不能当作财务规划。即使他们能够供养你，你仍然应该觉得，如果一切都糟透了，你们分手了，或者有人出轨了，或者发生了更糟的事情，你也能养活自己。你知道，通过金钱和财务进行的强迫控制也是一个非常现实的问题，当存在收入不平等时，这种控制往往会被放大。
So please just be smart. Please just don't completely rely on them. Even if they want you to, I always say like the person you marry, the person you start dating is not the person you break up with. They're not the person you divorce. So even if they're a great person right now and they're amazing and beautiful and wonderful and you never think that they could do anything like that, still just make sure it's in the back of your mind.
所以请务必保持清醒。请千万不要完全依赖他们。即使他们希望你这样做，我总是说，你结婚的人、你开始交往的人，并不是跟你分手的人。他们不是跟你离婚的人。所以，即使他们现在是个很好的人，而且他们很棒、很美、很完美，并且你永远不认为他们会做出那种事，但还是要在脑海深处留个心眼。
Make sure that you're still saying financially literate. And now we get to perhaps the biggest hurdle, the biggest life decision that may be different, which is around family and children. And also the timeline around those things. If you're a younger partner and you deeply want children and the older partner has grown children and doesn't want any more or it's just like past their reproductive years, this can create a real fundamental incompatibility. conversely you know if the older partner really wants kids doesn't have kids yet and wants them soon and
确保你依然具备财务素养。现在我们来到了也许是最大的障碍、最可能存在分歧的重大生活决定，那就是围绕家庭和孩子。以及关于这些事情的时间表。如果你是年轻的一方，并且极度渴望孩子，而年长的一方已经有了成年的孩子，并且不想再要孩子了，或者已经过了生育年龄，这可能会造成真正根本性的不相容。反过来，你知道，如果年长的一方真的很想要孩子，现在还没有孩子，并且希望很快拥有孩子，而
you're still kind of enjoying your free younger days that can also be difficult then there may even be an existing family dynamic that requires a lot of adjustment and understanding like are you ready to be a step-parent if you still feel like a child yourself are you ready to invest in a completely different kind of relationship you know because you may be able to walk away from a relationship, a romantic one, but I don't think you can walk away from children once they've come to trust you, once you are a member of their family. It's like that famous quote from Clueless, the movie, you know, you don't break up, you don't divorce children, you divorce the adult. So it is something to really like actually consider. These conversations
你还沉浸在自由的年轻时光中，这也是很困难的。接着，甚至可能存在一个现有的家庭动态，需要大量的调整和理解，比如：如果你自己感觉还像个孩子，你准备好当继父母了吗？你准备好投入到一种完全不同类型的人际关系中去了吗？你知道的，因为你或许可以离开一段恋爱关系，但我不认为一旦孩子们开始信任你、一旦你成为他们家庭的一员，你就能一走了之。就像电影《独领风骚》里的那句名言一样，你知道的，你不是和孩子分手，你不是和孩子离婚，你是和成年人离婚。所以这确实是需要真正去权衡的事情。这些对话
need to happen early and they have to happen with brutal honesty. Like honestly, like brutal honesty. You cannot expect someone to change their mind around this. They might change their mind. You cannot expect them to. I read this really amazing writing piece from a relationship coach and relationship expert. And she said one of the biggest reasons that she sees marriage as full apart is because one person wants kids, one person doesn't, and they both think that the other person is going change their mind. You don't have to know for sure, but if you do know, make sure you make that clear that that is what you want. Because again, it's all about resentment. Is a decision you make with the other person in mind, not yourself in mind going to make you resent them later on? Or can you
必须尽早展开，而且必须以极其诚实的方式进行。就像老实说的那样，必须做到极其诚实。你不能指望别人在这件事上改变主意。他们或许会改变主意。但你不能对此抱有期望。我读过一位关系教练和关系专家写的一篇非常精彩的文章。她说，她看到婚姻分崩离析的最大原因之一，就是一个人想要孩子，而另一个人不想要，并且双方都以为对方会改变主意。你不需要百分之百确定，但如果你确实知道，请务必明确表达这就是你想要的东西。因为同样地，这一切都关乎怨恨。一个以对方为中心、而不是以你自己为中心做出的决定，是否会让你在日后对他们产生怨恨？或者你能不能
take ownership of that decision as being yours? This asymmetry in life stages, it really does seem to be the biggest hurdle if you're in an age gap relationship. A very notable study in 2018 looked at the longitudinal data from thousands of Australian households and thousands of Australian marriages, and they found that whilst initial marital satisfaction might be higher for both men and women with younger spouses, that satisfaction does tend to decline more rapidly over time for couples with larger age gaps. And one of the speculations for this decline is precisely these different life stages and goals. For example, they suggest that couples of similar ages, they might be better able to understand each other. They might be able to better understand the developmental
把这个决定当作是你自己的来承担责任？这种人生阶段的不对称，似乎确实是身处年龄差恋爱关系中的最大障碍。2018年的一项非常著名的研究考察了数千个澳大利亚家庭和数千桩澳大利亚婚姻的纵向数据，他们发现，虽然年轻伴侣的初期婚姻满意度可能对男女双方都更高，但对于年龄差距较大的夫妻来说，这种满意度随着时间的推移确实往往下降得更快。而对这种下降的一种推测正是这些不同的人生阶段和目标。例如，他们指出，年龄相仿的夫妻可能更能理解彼此。他们可能更能理解配偶所处的发展阶段
and personal chapter that their spouse is in because they are also in it. The idea is that the bigger the age gap, the more likely the relationship will struggle with these phase of life related challenges. And this study really emphasizes, you know, age isn't just a number. We've kept, we've said that so many times. It's a reflection of potentially divergent pathways and different priorities. And that might be the hurdle. That might be the thing that undoes these relationships more than any other factor. we need to also return to this issue of power dynamics because it is a hot topic for a reason. We tend to automatically assume that the older partner will hold more power due to life
和个人篇章，因为他们也正身处其中。其核心观点是，年龄差距越大，这段关系就越有可能难以应对这些与生命阶段相关的挑战。这项研究着重强调，你知道，年龄不仅仅是一个数字。我们一直在说，已经说过很多次了。它是潜在的分歧道路和不同优先事项的反映。这可能就是障碍所在。比起任何其他因素，这可能正是摧毁这些关系的元凶。我们还需要回到权力动态这个问题上来，因为它成为热门话题是有原因的。我们往往会理所当然地认为，由于人生
experience and financial stability or more extensive social capital. And in some cases, like, yes, this can be true if one partner is significantly more wealthy or established, has more autonomy. me, they can kind of skew the balance in the relationship. But it's not a given. You know, a younger person, a 25 year old with a strong sense of self and clear boundaries and a great career and fierce independence, you know, it can be, it can be just as powerful and influential. Power isn't solely derived from age or income, but I do think that we need to protect ourselves against any kind of in balance.
经验、财务稳定或更广泛的社会资本，年长的一方将拥有更多的权力。在某些情况下，是的，如果一方明显更富有、更有社会地位、拥有更多自主权，这确实可能发生，他们可能会扭曲关系中的平衡。但这并非绝对。你知道，一个25岁的年轻人，如果有着强烈的自我意识、清晰的界限、出色的职业生涯和坚定的独立性，你知道，这也可以同样具有力量和影响力。权力并非仅源于年龄或收入，但我确实认为我们需要防范任何形式的不平衡。
When power, power should be held by both people equally in different forms. We want the ratio of our contributions to the outcomes of the relationship to be equal to our partners. This is a classic theory. It's called equity theory. And essentially it says that we are motivated to maintain fairness in our relationships. And if one partner consistently feels like someone is making more of this decision, someone is not taking accountability, someone is not giving as much as they are receiving, that can create a particular imbalance. It also comes down to resources, emotional labor,
当权力时，权力应该由两个人以不同的形式平等掌握。我们希望我们在关系中的贡献与关系结果的比例能够与伴侣相等。这是一个经典的理论。它被称为公平理论。从本质上讲，它表明我们有动力在关系中维护公平。如果一方始终觉得某人在这个决定中做出了更多决定，某人没有承担责任，某人付出的没有收到的多，这就会造成一种特殊的不平衡。这也归结于资源、情感劳动、
financial contributions, who gets to plan the dates, who picks the movies, who gets to make the life decisions when it is not 50-50 dissatisfaction is almost always guaranteed. For age gap relationships, I do think that achieving equity might require more explain, discussions because it may be that the older person does feel like they are more worthy of making decisions or can make decisions because they may be in a better elevated position. Do both partners feel heard? Do they feel like their needs being met? Do they feel respected? Do they feel valued for who they are and what they bring to the table? That is something that needs to constantly be calibrated in any relationship. This also leads me to talk about something called
财务贡献，谁来规划约会，谁来挑选电影，当事情并非五五开时，谁来做生活决策，不满几乎是不可避免的。对于年龄差恋爱关系，我确实认为实现公平可能需要更多解释和讨论，因为年长者可能确实觉得由于自己处于更有利的地位，他们更值得做决定，或者有能力做决定。双方都觉得自己被倾听了吗？他们觉得自己的需求得到了满足吗？他们觉得自己受到尊重了吗？他们是否因为自己是谁以及他们为这段关系带来了什么而感到被重视？这是任何关系中都需要不断校准的事情。这也引导我谈论一个概念，叫做
the teacher's student dynamic. And it's often the initial hook for the younger partner and why younger people find themselves with older people. They want their wisdom, they want their kind of demeanor, they want their mentorship, they enjoy sharing experiences. The dynamic can become problematic quickly if the younger partner becomes overly dependent on the teacher or is constantly seeking approval or direction to the point that it stifles their own growth and independence.
“师生动态”。这通常是吸引年轻伴侣的最初诱因，也是年轻人发现自己与年长者在一起的原因。他们渴望对方的智慧、他们那种风度、他们的指导，他们喜欢分享经历。如果年轻伴侣对“老师”过于依赖，或者不断寻求肯定和方向，以至于扼杀了他们自己的成长和独立性，这种动态就会迅速变得充满问题。
If the older partner becomes overly controlling, maternalistic, paternalistic, or dismissive of the younger partner's opinions just because of their age, it transforms from a healthy mentorship into an unhealthy student teacher power imbalance. It's not supportive. It turns an equal partnership into a hierarchy. A healthy age gap relationship really flourishes when the teacher's student role is fluid and reversible. The younger person is learning, the older person is learning, and they are growing together. I think this really brings me to discussing the main factor that is going to determine whether an age gap relationship is unhealthy or healthy, whether it is going to work or not work.
如果年长伴侣变得过于控制欲强、有如母亲般或父亲般过度保护，或者仅仅因为年龄而对年轻伴侣的观点不屑一顾，它就会从健康的指导转变为不健康的师生权力失衡。这不再是支持。它将平等的伙伴关系变成了一种等级制度。当师生角色变得流畅且可以互换时，健康的年龄差恋爱关系才会真正繁荣。年轻人正在学习，年长者也在学习，他们共同成长。我认为这确实让我开始讨论那个将决定年龄差恋爱关系是不健康还是健康、是会维系还是会破裂的主要因素。
And that is whether the partners just assume things about each other rather than learning from each other. Do they just assume what the other person is going to do? Do they just assume the dynamic? Do they just assume that someone is going to guide them or someone is going to follow along? Do they just assume that one of them is the provider, one of them is the giver, one of them is the receiver? do they just assume the future? You know, what might be an assumed next step for someone in their mid-20s, you know, like saving to go traveling for six months,
那就是，伴侣双方究竟是习惯于对彼此妄加猜测，还是去真正了解对方。他们是否只是盲目猜测对方会做什么？他们是否只是盲目猜测这种动态？他们是否只是猜测会由某人来引导，或者某人会顺从？他们是否只是猜测其中一人是经济提供者，一人是付出者，一人是接受者？他们是否只是对未来想当然？你知道，对于一个20多岁中期的人来说，可能被认为理所当然的下一步，你知道，比如攒钱去旅行六个月，
might be completely different to what is assumed for someone who was older, who might be saving for retirement. I don't know what are older people safe for, saving for a house, saving for something different. If they want different things and this is not discussed and either person is trying to force the other person to be on their path when they're not ready, that's insurmountable. It's never going to work.
可能与对于一个年长者的理所当然的想法完全不同，年长者可能在为退休攒钱。我不知道年长的人在攒什么钱，在为买房攒钱，为一些不同的事情攒钱。如果他们想要的东西不同，而这一点又没有经过讨论，并且任何一方都试图强迫另一方走上他们的道路而对方还没准备好，那这是不可逾越的鸿沟。这段关系永远不会成功。
Both of them are going to be unhappy. And that is really when we see that very dangerous power dynamic, take control. Okay. I feel like I've been quite doom and gloom for this last part. And the thing is, is that there are many, very, very. very successful age gap relationships. Even if people don't understand them from the outside, on the inside, they don't just survive, like they really thrive and these people are soulmates and they love each other.
双方都会不快乐。而这正是我们看到那种非常危险的权力动态占据主导地位的时候。好了。我觉得自己在最后这部分显得相当悲观和阴暗。但事实是，有许多、非常、非常成功的年龄差恋爱关系。即使外界的人不理解他们，但在内部，他们不仅能维持下去，而且确实繁荣发展，这些人是灵魂伴侣，他们深爱着彼此。
Why do they work? What makes a good age gap relationship versus a bad age gap relationship? We've talked about the bad, let's talk about the good. The most crucial factor, the most important factor in any relationship, but especially age gap ones are shared values, genuine interests, and an undeniable sense of emotional compatibility. We get so fixated on the age number that we forget to ask the most fundamental question. Do they laugh at the same jokes? Do they have similar ideas about loyalty, kindness, compassion? Do they both agree on what truly constitutes a good life?
为什么它们能行之有效？是什么造就了一段美好的年龄差恋爱关系，而不是糟糕的年龄差恋爱关系？我们已经谈过了糟糕的，让我们来谈谈美好的部分。在任何关系中，最关键的因素、最重要的因素，尤其是对于年龄差恋爱关系而言，是共同的价值观、真诚的兴趣以及不可否认的情感契合感。我们在年龄这个数字上过于执着，以至于忘记了问最根本的问题。他们会对同样的笑话开怀大笑吗？他们对忠诚、善良、同情心有相似的看法吗？他们对什么才真正构成了美好生活有共同的认同吗？
Did they enjoy doing similar things? One of my favorite studies of all time that was published in 2022 looked at these huge data sets that came from couples. And they consistently found that overall relationship satisfaction is linked far less to things like age, race and education level and far more to things like personality, compatibility, and shared experiences. And one of the biggest factors that will prove whether we're, a relationship will be successful or a couple will be successful is this thing called
他们喜欢做类似的事情吗？我最喜欢的有史以来的一项研究发表于2022年，它考察了来自情侣们的这些庞大数据集。他们一致发现，整体的婚姻满意度与年龄、种族和教育水平之类的因素联系要小得多，而与人格、契合度以及共同经历之类的因素联系要大得多。而将证明一段关系是否会成功、一对伴侣是否会成功的最大因素之一，就是被称为
perceived partner responsiveness. Do they get you? Do they truly care about your feelings? Do they engage with you? And there's an exercise to identify whether a relationship has this. It's a really simple exercise. You point out the window and you say, oh look, there's a bird. And you see what your partner does.
“感知到的伴侣回应度”的东西。他们懂你吗？他们真的关心你的感受吗？他们与你互动吗？有一个练习可以用来识别一段关系是否具备这种特质。这是一个非常简单的练习。你指着窗外说：“哦，看，那里有一只鸟。”然后你看你的伴侣会怎么做。
there's three options. They ignore you completely. They say something passive like, oh, that's nice, cool, but they don't really look. They don't really engage. Or they have an active response. They get up and they say, oh, my God, where is it? What kind of bird? Oh, let me see.
这里有三个选项。他们完全忽略你。他们说一些被动的话，比如：“哦，挺好的，酷，”但他们并没有真的去看。他们没有真正参与进来。或者他们有积极的反应。他们站起来说：“哦，天哪，它在哪？什么鸟？哦，让我看看。
Oh, maybe we should do this. Maybe we should do that. What a beautiful bird? What noise is it making? What does it look like? They care about what you're seeing. They care about your life. They care about life through your eyes.
哦，也许我们该这样做？也许我们该那样做？多美的一只鸟啊？它在发出什么声音？它长什么样？”他们关心你看到的东西。他们关心你的生活。他们通过你的眼睛关心生活。
I did this with my partner recently. and he immediately, he didn't ask, let me see. He wasn't like, oh, what does it look like? He goes, well, now I need to build a bird house. Now we have to build the bird house. Like if there are birds outside, well, and if you like the birds, you know, we need that. And I was like, it just made me swoon because I was like, wow, it really shows that you are interested in this simply because I am interested in it. Try this with your partner at your own risk.
我最近和我的伴侣做过这个测试。他立刻，他没有问“让我看看”。他也没有说“哦，它长什么样？”，而是说：“好吧，现在我得建一个鸟屋了。现在我们得建鸟屋了。”就像如果外面有鸟，而且如果你喜欢鸟，你知道，我们就需要这个。当时我简直心动得晕眩，因为我想：“哇，这真的表明你对这个感兴趣，仅仅是因为我对这个感兴趣。”请自行承担风险与你的伴侣尝试这个吧。
But, you know, there is no formula for what makes a relationship. work and what doesn't? You know, a 25-year-old and a 45-year-old can be in love for the same reason that a 25-year-old and 25-year-old are in love. It may have absolutely nothing to do with their birth year. The attraction in many cases is simply based on finding another human who you connect with, who you click with, who is responsive to you, irrespective of when they were born. And those are the couples that succeed regardless of age. And as long as they really have respect. That's like the secret to any relationship. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, we have some listener questions and dilemmas, including a dilemma from
但是，你知道，对于一段关系为什么能成功、为什么会失败，并没有什么固定的公式。你知道，一个25岁的人和一个45岁的人可以相爱，其原因和一个25岁的人和一个25岁的人相爱可能完全一样。这可能与他们的出生年份完全没有关系。在许多情况下，吸引力纯粹基于找到另一个与你心灵相通、与你一拍即合、对你有所回应的人，而不管他们是什么时候出生的。无论年龄大小，这样的情侣都能获得成功。只要他们真正拥有尊重。这就是任何关系的秘诀。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我们将解答听众的一些问题和困惑，其中包括来自
a listener about her sister who was dating someone 30 years, her senior questions around how to handle being a stepdad and what to do when your parent is dating someone your age. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the state. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience
一位听众的困惑，关于她的姐姐正在与一位比自己大30岁的人约会，以及如何处理当好继父的问题，还有当你的父母在和一个与你同龄的人约定时该怎么办。所有这些以及更多内容，就在这段短暂的休息之后。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，穿透主宰健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾。
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never messes. with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season
我们真的曾以为种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》，也就是“TWO%”，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会获得愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德，在这部新季的
of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. hands. I said, oh hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it
《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。丰满的双手。我说：“哦，见鬼，绝不。”我发誓我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过往》
podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我愿意在节目里谈论快克，只是为了让你们所有人知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过往》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核学习》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们
get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
会如此全神贯注于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们却仍在追逐它。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在记分牌上盯着看。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯。
Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
因为你觉得作为地球上的人做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们将在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、
pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So as you guys know, every episode we have started doing listener questions where I go on Instagram, I tell you what topics are going to be discussing. And I say, shoot, shoot for the stuff. When do you guys want to know, what do you want to hear about? What dilemmas do you have so that I can answer them in the episode, instead of waiting until
压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《硬核学习》并立即收听。所以正如大家所知，从每一集开始，我们都开始做听众问答环节，我会在Instagram上发帖，告诉大家我们将要讨论哪些话题。然后我说，尽管放马过来。大家想知道什么，想听什么？你们有什么困惑，这样我就可以在节目中回答你们的问题，而不是一直等到
the episode comes out, to kind of answer your questions. This episode, we got a lot of dilemmas, a lot of dilemmas from listeners who are dealing with some prickly age gap situations. This first story comes from, I'm not going to say her name, but someone whose sister is dating someone 30 years her senior. Hi, Gemma. I'm having a little bit of an issue with something going on. in my life right now. My sister, who is two years older than me, is currently dating someone who is
节目播出时，才来解答你们的问题。这一期节目中，我们收到了很多困惑，许多来自正在应对棘手的年龄差情况的听众的困惑。这个第一则故事来自，我不会说出她的名字，但某个人的姐姐正在和一位比她大30岁的人约会。嗨，杰玛。我的生活中目前遇到了一点小麻烦。我的姐姐比我大两岁，她目前正在和一个
57. She is 27 and for whatever reason, I know I shouldn't, but I find this situation very icky. She wants to bring him to an upcoming birthday party that I'm holding and I'm really not comfortable with that. I know that they are serious and that they have been together for some time now, but I'm unsure about his intentions with her and I feel like I should say something or I should show in some way my disapproval for this relationship. On the other hand, I really want to be supportive and I love her and we are very close. This person has put a real buffer between me and her and it's making me deeply uncomfortable. What should I do?
57岁的人约会。她今年27岁，不管出于什么原因，我知道我不应该这样想，但我发现这种情况非常令人倒胃口。她想带他参加我即将举办的一个生日派对，我对这一点真的感到很不自在。我知道他们是认真的，而且已经在一起一段时间了，但我对他的意图感到不确定，我觉得我应该说点什么，或者我应该以某种方式表现出我对这段关系的不满。另一方面，我真的很想给予支持，而且我爱她，我们的关系非常亲密。这个人在这我和她之间制造了一道真正的隔阂，这让我感到极度不适。我该怎么办？
This is a really hard situation. Let me tell you honestly what I would be doing and then what I think. think my higher self would want me to do and maybe what you should do. If my sister came to me and said that she was dating someone in her 50s, I would immediately feel really uncomfortable about it. It would just be a knee-jerk reaction. I probably wouldn't be happy about it. I probably would tell her and we would probably have a huge fire and it would be very
这是一个非常棘手的局面。老实说，我来告诉你我会怎么做，然后是我认为更好的自我会希望我怎么做，以及也许你应该怎么做。如果我姐姐来找我说她在和五十多岁的人约会，我立刻会对此感到非常不舒服。这只会是一种下意识的反应。我可能不会高兴。我大概会告诉她，然后我们可能会大吵一架，那将会非常
uncomfortable. That's what I would do if I wasn't in my right mind and wasn't thinking properly. As a more rational perspective, I think what you need to say is, I think you really need to ask yourself some questions. Is she happy? Do I trust in her ability to handle situations like this on her own? Do I trust her judgment about these situations? Is she being safe? Financially, you know, is she being safe in terms of life decisions? Is she making decisions that you think she genuinely wants to make or is it being guided by this man? Does she want kids? Is that a discussion that you think that they are having? This is just all questions to ask yourself to make you feel more
令人尴尬。如果我当时神智不清、思考不周全的话，我就会这么做。从一个更理性的角度来看，我认为你需要说的话是，我觉得你真的需要问自己一些问题。她快乐吗？我信任她自己处理这种局面的能力吗？我信任她对这些情况的判断力吗？她安全吗？在财务上，你知道的，她在生活决策方面安全吗？她做出的决定是你认为她真心想做的，还是在这个男人的引导下做出的？她想要孩子吗？你认为他们在讨论这个话题吗？这只是所有需要问你自己的问题，好让你感到更
at ease with the fact that she is a grown woman. Nothing you say or do will probably force them to break up. If anything, it's an age old, it's an age old tale that you tell someone you don't like their boyfriend and you're the one who's going to get cut out of their life. So if you are genuinely worried about her and her safety or her well-being or that she's making a mistake, staying close to her and being able to monitor that as someone who is on her good side is probably better. You know, it's going to be worse if you isolate her by saying that you don't approve when maybe at this point nothing is actually wrong. Maybe they really do just have a great relationship and you just are yet to understand it. Maybe you will come around to it. Maybe you'll
心安，因为她毕竟是一个成年人。你所说或所做的一切大概都无法强迫他们分手。如果真要说的话，这是一个古老的传说：你告诉别人你不喜欢他们的男友，而你反而成了那个被从他们生活中切断联系的人。所以，如果你真的担心她、担心她的安全或她的幸福，或者担心她正在犯错，那么保持与她的亲密关系，并作为一个站在她好意一边的人去监督这一点，可能会更好。你知道的，如果你通过表达不赞同来将她孤立起来，情况会更糟，而此时可能根本没有任何问题。也许他们真的拥有一段极好的关系，而你只是还没能理解。也许你以后会转变看法。也许你以后会以
see it in a different light later on. You've also got to remember like it's her life and she has to make some of those mistakes herself. As much as we love our siblings and we love our friends and we love the people we love, we cannot control their lives for them. Maybe this is just something that she has to experience. Maybe it all turn out really, really well. You don't know. I would say, my highest self would say,
一种不同的眼光看待它。你还得记住，这是她的人生，她必须自己去犯一些那样的错误。尽管我们深爱着我们的兄弟姐妹，我们深爱着我们的朋友，我们深爱着我们所爱的人，但我们无法替他们掌控他们的人生。也许这只是她必须经历的事情。也许一切最终都会非常、非常美好。你并不知道。我会说，我内心更高尚的自我会建议，
ignore the instinct to get angry and to say something and just observe and wait to see if there is really a reason that you need to step in. And good luck. Our second question of the day, how do you deal with dating someone who already has kids? I'm not ready to be a step-parent, but I feel like I'll have to be because I love this person so much. That is a crazy dilemma and something that I've personally never encountered. I've never been a step-parent. I've never been a parent. What I really think that you should be doing is having as many open conversations with your partner as
忽略那种想要生气、想要说些什么的情绪，只需观察并等待，看看是否真的有必要介入。祝你好运。我们的第二个问题，如何与一个已经有孩子的人谈恋爱？我还没准备好当继父母，但我觉得我不得不这样做，因为我太爱这个人了。这是一个疯狂的困境，也是我个人从未遇到过的情况。我从来没当过继父母。我也从来没当过父母。我真正认为你应该做的是，与你的伴侣展开尽可能多的
possible. Firstly, you need to get clear on whether they see a really serious future with you. Because if they don't, there's no point worrying about investing in their family if they have no plan to make you part of that family. You also need to really ask yourself, am I prepared for my life to fully change? Once you are a parent, even if you are a step-parent, that is a huge responsibility. Take some time to really think about whether you are ready for that life chapter because it is it will be the end of some things that you can do and of a life that you may have thought you are going to have be really serious with yourself around whether which life you want more and which life and whether you think this new life is one that you are ready for it's
公开对话。首先，你需要弄清楚他们是否真的视你为他们认真未来的另一半。因为如果他们不这么认为，如果他们没有计划让你成为那个家庭的一部分，那么担心如何融入他们的家庭就毫无意义。你还需要真正问自己，我准备好让生活发生翻天覆地的变化了吗？一旦你成为父母，即使你是继父母，这也是一项巨大的责任。花点时间好好想想你是否准备好了迎接人生的那个新阶段，因为它将意味着你可以做的一些事情的结束，以及你原本以为自己会拥有的生活的结束。对自己认真一点，想清楚你更想要哪种生活，以及你是否认为这种新生活是你已经准备好迎接的，因为这
a lot of responsibility you need to have really open discussions around what your role in their life is going to be it's going to be what their relationship with their ex partner is like what your relationship with their ex-partner will be like, what your relationship with their kids will be like, custody arrangements, time apart, whether your plans for the future line up, if you want to go travel, like, are you going to have to go travel with the kids? Like you, the more information, the better. I also think that, you know, if you're going to walk away, now's the time before you have met them.
是一项沉重的责任。你需要就你在他们生活中的角色进行非常坦诚的讨论，包括他们与前伴侣的关系是怎样的，你与他们前伴侣的关系会是怎样的，你与他们孩子的关系会是怎样的，抚养权安排，各自的时间分配，你们对未来的规划是否契合，如果你想去旅行，就像，你得带着孩子们一起去旅行吗？就像，信息越多越好。我还认为，你知道，如果你打算抽身离去，现在就是时候，在你们还没见面之前。
Best of luck. I think that's really, really tough. I know you'll make the right decision, though, and I'm sure that the fact that you're already thinking about it means that you're going to be an amazing step-parent if that's what you choose to do or you're going to make the right choice for you and be an amazing person without this person as well, even if it's a hard choice. All right. Our third question for the day. Help. My dad is dating a woman who is my age. Technically one year older than me, but still she's 26. What do I say? I can get the discomfort here.
祝你好运。我认为这真的非常艰难。但我知道你会做出正确的决定，而且我相信，既然你已经在思考这个问题了，这意味着如果你选择这样做，你将成为一个了不起的继父母，或者你会为自己做出正确的选择，即使这是一个艰难的选择，你也能在没有这个人的情况下成为一个了不起的人。好的。我们的第三个问题。救命。我爸爸在和一个跟我同龄的女人约会。严格来说比我大一岁，但不管怎样，她26岁。我该说些什么？我能理解这里的这种不舒服感。
As much as I have been pro age gap relationships, of course, healthy age gap relationships, this does feel kind of uncomfortable. I think I would give you the same advice as I gave the first person, which is until it becomes a problem, don't express an opinion, but definitely have strong boundaries around when you see her, if she's invited to family events, what you guys talk about. be really clear that like she is not your friend. She is your father's girlfriend until the relationship has been proven to be stable
尽管我一直支持年龄差恋爱关系，当然是指健康的年龄差恋爱关系，但这确实让人感觉有点不舒服。我想我会给你和第一个人一样的建议，那就是在它成为问题之前，不要表达任何意见，但对于你什么时候见她、她是否被邀请参加家庭活动以及你们谈论的话题，一定要设定清晰的界限。一定要非常明确地表明，她不是你的朋友。在关系被证明是稳定之前，她只是你父亲的女朋友
until you can really see the direction that it's going in. Again, you know, it's kind of hard because it's none of your business, but it is also a whole lot of your business. So I think just like hopefully you have siblings who you can talk to this about. Be welcoming, but she doesn't have to be your friend. you don't really have to invest in their relationship emotionally until it's proven that it's gone beyond a point. And just be really clear around like what you will and won't talk about with this person, what your, what is, what your father expects from you in terms of, yeah, being around this
直到你真正能看出这段关系的发展方向。同样，你知道，这有点难，因为这不关你的事，但这也完全是你的事。所以我想就像，希望你有兄弟姐妹可以和他们商量这事。保持欢迎的态度，但她不必是你的朋友。在被证明已经超越某个阶段之前，你其实不必在情感上投入到他们的关系中。并且要非常明确地界定，对于这个人，你愿意和不愿意谈论什么，你父亲对你在陪伴这个人方面，有什么样的期望。
person. And if he's expecting too much, just be like, hey, I find this weird. And if you can't see the fact that this is weird, you're going to have to deal with that. But I need to protect my peace against the weirdness of this. And yeah, hopefully we can have mature adult discussions. about it, but yeah, I can, gosh, wishing you guys all a lot of luck. There's a lot of complicated relationships out there. This is what this episode is really teaching me, but I know you can handle it and I get your discomfort, but the relationship might not be forever. Just, it might not stand the test of time.
人。如果他期望太多，就直接说，嘿，我觉得这很诡异。如果你看不到这很诡异的事实，那你得自己去处理。但我需要保护我的内心，远离这种诡异感。希望我们能对此进行成熟的成年人讨论，天哪，祝你们好运。外面有很多复杂的感情，这也是这一期节目真正教给我的，但我知道你们能应付，我也理解你们的不适，但这段感情可能不会是永远的，它可能经不起时间的考验。
Go see a therapist about the more complex Freudian parts of that. And my God, I just, why is my only advice good luck? I really feel like that's all I can say. Good luck. I'm ready for our final question. I actually got this quite a lot, which is, is it true? that women are more emotionally mature than men and develop faster, hence why they are attracted to older partners compared to someone their own age.
去找治疗师聊聊其中更复杂的弗洛伊德式部分吧。天哪，我为什么唯一的建议就是祝你好运？我真的觉得这就是我所能说的全部了。祝你好运。我准备好回答我们的最后一个问题了。实际上我经常收到这个问题，那就是：女性真的比男性在情感上更成熟、发育更快吗？因此，相比同龄人，她们才会被年长的伴侣吸引？
So this is a myth. Sush, I don't even know if it's a myth. This is just an idea that has been circling around for a while. It is true that girls often mature faster than boys at a younger age. So basically when we are teenagers, when we're children, girls, their brains will develop faster. They will gain better working memory, greater emotional regulation, better cognitive skills earlier compared to boys. There is a debate whether that is because of social conditioning or because of just biological blueprint. That's just how women's brains works or is it that their learning environment is making it so that they pick up on these skills faster?
所以这是一个神话。嘘，我甚至不知道这算不算神话。这只是一个流传了一段时间的观点。确实，在较小的时候，女孩往往比男孩成熟得更快。所以基本上当我们还是青少年、还是孩子的时候，女孩的大脑发育会更快。与男孩相比，她们能更早地获得更好的工作记忆、更强的情绪调节能力和更好的认知技能。至于这是因为社会规训，还是仅仅因为生物学蓝图——也就是女性大脑本来就是这样运作的，抑或是她们的学习环境使得她们能更快地掌握这些技能，目前还有争论。
because more is expected of them compared to boys. However, as we get older around the age of 18 to 22, the gap definitely starts to become smaller. It definitely starts to become narrower so that men and women have a very similar intellectual capacity, a very similar level of emotional maturity, or their brains have a similar capacity for emotional. maturity, similar levels of working memory, etc, etc. So I don't know whether this is entirely
因为人们对她们的期望比对男孩高。然而，随着我们长大，在大约18到22岁左右，这个差距绝对开始缩小。它确实开始变窄，使得男女拥有非常相似的智力水平、非常相似的情感成熟度水平，或者说他们的大脑在情感成熟度方面有相似的容量，相似的工作记忆水平，等等，等等。所以我不知道这是否完全
true. One study did find that men don't reach peak mental maturity until 43 whilst women typically mature around 32. But I think there needs to be more research. I do think that what it really comes down is personal preferences and to maybe the condition preferences of women to get serious quicker, especially since there's a real stigma around being single, the perceived pressure on women to have children younger because of the biological clock factor. But yeah, it's a very complex question. I would say right now it's definitely based on, it's an individual thing rather than a generalized thing that we can say women are more mature than men. We can prove this using these scientific and statistical models.
真实。一项研究确实发现，男性直到43岁才达到精神成熟的巅峰，而女性通常在32岁左右成熟。但我认为还需要更多的研究。我确实认为，这真正归结于个人偏好，以及女性想要更快安定下来的条件反射般的偏好，特别是考虑到单身面临着的真正社会耻辱，以及由于生物钟因素给女性带来的年轻生子的感知压力。但这是一个非常复杂的问题。我现在想说，这绝对是基于个人情况，而不是一个普遍规律，我们不能说女性一定比男性更成熟。我们无法用这些科学和统计模型来证明这一点。
Therefore, that's why women date older. But it's a very, very interesting question. I hope you guys really enjoyed this episode. It's definitely complex. It's layered. Again, I really welcome disagreement. If you have a different perspective on this, I really don't have all the answers. So leave a comment below your experience in age gap relationships, the experiences of friends
因此，这就是为什么女性喜欢和年长的人约会。但这真的是一个非常非常有趣的问题。我希望大家真的很享受这一期节目。它绝对是复杂的，是有层次的。再次说明，我非常欢迎不同的意见。如果你对此有不同的看法，我真的并非掌握了所有的答案。所以请在下方留言，分享你在年龄差恋爱中的经历、你朋友的
of yours, something, an argument or an element of this, you didn't think we covered just so that we can keep the discussion going on down there. I just hope this episode gave you some food for thought, some insights, perhaps a gentle nudge towards rethinking any stereotypes that you may have because I definitely had them. But as always, make sure that you leave a five-star review, that you are following us wherever you are listening on Apple Podcasts, on Spotify. It really does help new people find us. And that is such a gift, such a blessing to have new listeners wherever they are in the
经历，或者你认为我们没有涵盖的某个论点或某个要素，好让那里的讨论继续下去。我只希望这期节目能给你们带来一些启迪、一些见解，或许能温和地推动你们重新思考你们可能存在的任何刻板印象，因为我以前确实也有。但老样子，请务必留下五星好评，无论你在哪里收听，都要关注我们——在Apple Podcasts上，在Spotify上。这真的能帮助新听众找到我们。无论他们身在世界的哪个角落，拥有新听众都是一份如此美妙的礼物和祝福，
world. and whatever content they choose to engage with, just having more members of the community is always brilliant. Make sure that you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to contribute to our listener questions, these ones were juicy. So if you've got another question on this episode or another episode that's coming up, that's the best place to deliver it. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself.
无论他们选择参与什么内容，有更多社区成员加入总是太棒了。请确保在Instagram上关注我：@That Psychology Podcast。如果你想为我们的听众问答环节做出贡献，这些问题可太精彩了。所以如果你对这期节目或即将播出的另一期节目有其他问题，那是最好的提交地方。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。
And we will talk very, very soon. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your personal.
我们很快就会再聊。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取个人频道的任何地方上的TWA%。
Podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何和朋友、同僚喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起挺过来的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是个疯狂的年份。我的意思是，这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有牌照的
professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
专业人士一起交谈。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。人类保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。